[Music]
welcome back to cbs saturday morning
this year mark the first time an
american president has proclaimed an
official indigenous people's day
observance activists have sought to use
columbus day to refocus on indigenous
communities on monday native american
and environmental activists protested
outside the white house demanding the
government take greater action on
climate change this demonstration comes
50 years after the end of another
protest led by native americans on the
site of one of america's most notorious
prisons
sunrise over san francisco bay and a
morning of prayer
brought 1500 native americans from
574 tribes this week to what has become
sacred ground
[Music]
alcatraz once called the harshest
federal penitentiary in u.s history
also ignited a movement
on november 20 1969
protesters took over the rock island
declaring it native land citing the 1868
treaty of fort laramie which gave native
americans rights to abandon federal
property there was no water heat or
power
just empty prison cells and crumbling
buildings young people you know you
don't get cold because you know we come
from reservations and communities where
we don't have a lot of things and a lot
of conveniences lynetta warjack brought
fellow native american students from
berkeley richard oakes who planned the
occupation led classmates from san
francisco state 89 of us that landed on
the island we did it in protest of the
broken treaties the poor policies the
fact that they had denied us our culture
and our heritage this was a huge
declaration and a huge statement
university of kansas professor kent
blanson has written extensively about
the takeover this was a massive media
event it was stage theater the rock is
kind of like our march on washington
it's kind of like our i have a dream
speech in regards to creating a greater
indigenous future
today when tourists arrive on alcatraz
they can't help but be reminded of that
the national park service both manages
this site and preserves its past we are
the only national park site out of more
than 420 national park sites in the
country that preserves a modern native
american story steven cote a park
service historian curated an exhibit of
the occupation you go to another park
that was native american land or maybe
there was a battle there or a massacre
those are older stories right we're a
modern native american story the
occupiers are still here with us
they're still helping us to tell this
story that's richard oaks grandson right
there eloy martinez was a young
organizer in the occupation urban res
life a child in it is that you this is
my mom uh-huh this right here is me we
were getting on the boat to come to the
island you remember it like it was
yesterday yes i do because it was my
stable part of my life
and when you're a child of an activist
that your family is all over the place
when you're staying somewhere for three
weeks
that's stable and i was safe here you
felt safe i felt safe here much of what
is in this exhibit was collected by kent
blanson every piece too it felt like it
was filling a gap in our historical
narrative it felt like it was getting us
one step closer to the truth of the
importance and significance of this
massive event in american history i
remember my little dance i used to do
too what was it i used to go say it loud
i'm red and i'm proud and i would always
put my fist up
the occupation lasted a year six months
and 22 days as a child did you
understand what you were fighting for
no i did not it took a while for me to
get on the island to understand and the
first memory that i have was getting off
the boat and seeing the teepee you were
two of 89
occupiers why did you want to be a part
of this movement
because i've been in jail i know how our
people are always getting treated we're
always on the short end of the stick
that's what made me get involved the
occupation ended on june 11 1971
a footnote in the memory of mainstream
america but its legacy did live it's
really the spark that ignited the red
power movement that triggered hundreds
of other takeovers and protests
that would eventually culminate in about
29 pieces of self-determination
legislation sponsored by
richard nixon all the way up into
jimmy carter's administration
[Music]
the descendants of the occupiers are now
the hope for the future it's stronger
with our young people that are out there
fighting the fight for our water for our
missing murdered indigenous women and on
alcatraz at least a space that was once
a prison laundry will air out a past for
the present if we were to have a
cultural center permanently here we
would be able to showcase the history
the way that it really happened that
it's it's not something that was uh made
up and that they'll know that we're real
people that we're not mascots of
football teams or real people
and you know i'm a native of california
i never heard of this
so much of san francisco the bay area at
that time
was a collective of people standing up
for themselves from the black panthers
to the red movement it really showcased
how people came together to fight for a
common cause that i matter when you
visit alcatraz you see little things and
notices of native americans and graffiti
and whatnot and a lot of it now makes
more sense yeah had you heard of it no i
mean and going i've been alcatraz too
and don't remember seeing it but that
was decades ago the occupation lasted
for how long uh 19 months oh
all right michelle great story thank you